digamos que queremos calcular 78 entre
12 qué resultado obtenemos pausa el
vídeo e inténtalo bueno una forma de
pensarlo es que esto es lo mismo que 78
dividido entre 12 parece que he dicho lo
mismo pero a la derecha escribí 78
doceavos es decir 78 dividido entre 12
ahora como podemos expresar esto bueno
pensemos en algún múltiplo de 12 cercano
a 78 sin exceder lo sabemos que 12 por
560 y 12 por 6 72 12 por 7 84 así que 12
por 7 excede a 78 por lo tanto podemos
escribir este numerador como en lugar de
poner 78 escribiré el múltiplo de 12 más
cercanos 78 que conocemos más lo que nos
sobra 72 más 6
es lo mismo que 78 y esto dividido entre
ahora puedo expresar esto como 72 272
entre 12 + 6 entre 12 a 612 amos
bien cuál es el resultado de 72 entre 12
bueno sabemos que 72 es 6 veces 12
entonces tengo 6 por 2 entre 12 y esto
se simplifica en 6 después tengo 6 12
ambos ya que equivale bueno puedes
reconocer que 6 es la mitad de 12 o
puedes dividir el numerador y el
denominador a ambos por 6 y de cualquier
manera obtendrás un medio así que puedes
ver todo esto como 6 más un medio o 6
enteros y un medio en un futuro no
necesitarás hacer todos estos pasos
entre más practiques todo esto pero esta
vez los hice porque quería asegurarme de
que entendieran lo que está sucediendo
entonces esto es lo mismo que seis
enteros un medio y si lo queremos
expresar como decimal lo podemos
escribir como seis unidades y cuántos
décimos un medio es lo mismo que cinco
décimos
así que 6
y cinco décimos 6.5
ya está esta fue una forma de obtener el
resultado del 78 entre 12 bien hagamos
otro ejemplo cuál es el resultado de 20
entre 80 pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta
bueno podemos usar una técnica similar
podemos decir que esto es lo mismo que
20 80 vos o escribir 20 en el numerador
y 80 en el denominador es decir esto es
lo mismo que 20 / 80 y después pensar en
cómo podemos simplificar esta fracción o
expresarla de una forma distinta bueno
podemos escribir el numerador como una
vez 20 1 por 20 y escribir el
denominador como 4 veces 20 4 por 20
entonces podemos ver esto como un cuarto
por 20 entre 20 pero a qué equivale 20
entre 20 pero esto es simplemente 1 así
que todo esto se simplifica en un cuarto
muy bien ahora como expresamos un cuarto
como un decimal
bueno es un poco difícil expresar un
cuarto en decimos porque 4 no divide
fácilmente a 10 pero podemos expresar lo
en términos de centésimos o un cuarto es
lo mismo que 25 entre 100 es decir es lo
mismo que 25 centésimos y puedes llegar
a ello multiplicando el numerador y el
denominador por 25 y la razón del porqué
me interesan los centésimos es que ahora
sabemos cómo representarse en tenemos en
decimales esto es lo mismo que será
unidades y 25 centésimos 0.25
así que 20 entre 80 es lo mismo que 25
entre 100 y 25 centésimos así que una
vez más todas estas son distintas
estrategias para pensar en cómo podemos
dividir números y obtener un resultado
con decimales